valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france est l'invitée de
preuves par 3 bonsoir valérie bègue sera
et merci d'être présente à ce rendez
vous de public sénat et de la sp en ce
moment dramatique ce nouvel accablement
qui nous affecte tous bien sûr après les
attentats de bruxelles compassion
solidarité avec notre voisin frappé en
son coeur plusieurs dizaines de morts
une action dans la capitale européenne
signée du groupe etat islamique alors
comment renforcer encore la sécurité
comment lutter contre la radicalisation
dans nos quartiers ses questions étaient
très présentes dans votre campagne
elles sont évidemment d'une brûlante
d'actualité et d'ailleurs vous les avez
à nouveau abordée aujourd'hui avec le
ministre d'intérieur qui vous a reçu
tout à l'heure dans son bureau alors que
votre élection eh bien il y a raconté il
ya exactement cent jours vous avez vu le
calendrier est bien sûr nous dresserons
également dans cette émission avec
michaël szames s de public sénat un
premier bilan de vos actions et puis
nadège poljak de la fp sur elle a
ensuite pour des questions plus
politiques avec bien sûr en vue la
primaire qui qui se dessine pour les
républicains
d'abord valérie pécresse kehl quelles
ont été vos premières pensées en
apprenant ce matin ses nouveaux
attentats terrible d'abord une grande
tristesse
et puis évidemment le sentiment que nous
avons tous que personne
ne peut être épargné ne peut se
considérer aujourd'hui comme épargné
nulle part dans le monde
aujourd'hui il n'ya d'abris contre 7
cette guerre terroriste donc cela ajoute
aux responsabilités des élus non vous
êtes en ile de france particulièrement
bien entendu bien entendu puisqu'on voit
que les capitales européennes sont
particulièrement ciblés la belgique
c'est à quelques encablures de la france
ça arrive directement par la gare du
nord en ile de france donc
donc évidemment il ya il ya des vases
communicants qui sont importants et puis
il faut pas se cacher la vérité tout ça
est quand même très liée à l'arrestation
de salles abdeslam c'est-à-dire aux
attentats de paris il y à une fine art
belge qui a commis déjà des attendus à
paris quels sont les points que vous
avez abordé avec le ministre de
l'intérieur qu'on va écouter dans un
instant je les appelais dès la matinée
dès qu'on a su dès qu'on a su la
nouvelle pour parler avec lui des
transports en ile-de-france alors les
transports en ile de france nous avions
déjà une vigilance extrême mais il faut
il ne faut pas relâcher nos efforts et
c'est vrai que dès qu'il se passe trois
semaines un mois deux mois de calme on
pourrait être tenté de relâcher la
vigilance donc il ne faut pas relâcher
la vigilance et au contraire moi ce que
je lui proposais ce matin et nous allons
nous revoir la semaine prochaine pour en
parler c'est d'accélérer la mise en
place d'un certain nombre de mesures que
nous avons voté dans le cadre du
bouclier de sécurité franciliens alors
ce qu'il faut mettre en place
et bien c'est notamment un certain
nombre d'équipements de sécurité de
nouvelles technologies pour détecter par
exemple les comportements suspects par
le biais de sur les quais des gares
je voudrais aussi qu' on puisse engager
très vite et c'est un plan que j'ai
proposé ce matin la modernisation du
matériel roulant parce que là aussi
alors ça va prendre plus de temps bien
entendu c'est sur du plus long terme
mais il nous faut aussi de la vidéo
protection dans donc les rams avec un
acteur également aujourd'hui
la rénovation des trains qu'il y aura
des portiques par exemple comme les élus
les ont proposés également je pense au
sud de la france alors moi je crois
beaucoup beaucoup plus je crois à deux
choses je crois d'abord à des outils de
détection un peu innovant technologique
technologique et un peu moins voyons ce
que le problème des portiques c'est que
de toute façon ils sont impraticables en
ile de france nous avons quatre millions
de personnes qui prennent les transports
en commun tous les jours 4 millions
c'est à dire qu en ile-de-france y en a
plus que sur tout l'été avec tous les
tgv 2 france entière lorsque la vérité
c'est que vous pouvez pas mettre un
portique aujourd'hui à la gare du
chagrin auquel chillon vous avez une
émeute et vous ne pourrez de toutes les
façons pas rentrer ça commence à mettre
en place à en paca comme on dit en
ile-de-france non il faut pas y compter
après ça dépend des lieux et ça dépend
des situations nous en ile de france
ça ne servira à rien pourquoi je vous
donnerai simplement l'explication c'est
que à châtelet ou mettre des portiques
embolie serait complètement la guerre du
châtelet mais à côté de ça vous avez un
réseau maillé de de centaines de gares
donc la vérité c'est qu'il suffirait de
monter dans une petite gare de banlieue
et à ce moment là on aurait pas de
portiques donc la vérité c'est que le
portique n'est pas une panacée en
matière de sécurité en revanche il ya
deux choses qui sont très importantes
c'est la présence humaine et c'est la
vidéoprotection avec des personnes qui
derrière la vidéo en direct ci aurait ce
qui se passe mais il ya aussi des outils
un peu plus technologique par exemple
d'aider des détecteurs d'armes qui sont
pas forcément une sportive sous
lesquelles on masse mais qui peuvent dés
on a des outils qui peuvent détecter
quand on passe devant
donc en fait vous allez accélérée
pourrait faire é plan de tous voilà
l'idée c'est d'avoir du matériel qui à
certains points stratégiques et sans que
évidemment les terroristes ne le sache
pourrait détecter encore des choses et
nous permettre d'avoir du renseignement
donc ça c'est très important et on veut
accélérer
j'allais dire cette espèce et vous cei à
la police scientifique a permis
d'élucider beaucoup de crimes
et puis aujourd'hui il ya des
protections scientifique un peu
innovante et ça on veut aller dessus
très vite
par ailleurs on a un autre un autre
sujet qui est la présence humaine
bernard cazeneuve m'a confirmé qu'il y
aurait plusieurs centaines de forces de
police on va l'écouter parce qu'il
annonce le chiffre le ministre de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui a dit ce matin
dès les attaques de bruxelles connue
j'ai décidé de déployer mille 600
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
en différents points du territoire à la
fois sur les contrôles aux frontières
mais également dans les infrastructures
de transports aériens maritimes et
ferroviaires 3600 en plus comment ça se
passe avec le ministre de l'intérieur il
ya une volonté bien sûr commune
d'aborder de front les deux sujets oui
alors le miss à l'intérieur lui à une
meilleure connaissance et moquée qui en
charge
mais sur l'île de france moi mon message
a été simple c'est que je souhaitais que
les 400 policiers et militaires
supplémentaires qui aujourd'hui sont
déployés sur la région sur le réseau
francilien puisse être aussi déployés
dans les gares de grande couronne qu'on
n'ait pas le sentiment qu hier
finalement une sécurité à deux vitesses
d'abord une sécurité dans le métro dans
le coeur de paris et que en réalité tout
le reste du réseau soit oubliée donc il
m'a garanti qu'effectivement il y aurait
les patrouilles dans les trains et dans
les gares
y compris sur le réseau de camp rock
roll alors l'idée c'est évidemment on
peut pas tout surveiller tout le temps
au même moment
mais l'idée c'est de faire de procéder
par sonde de faire des contrôles
d'identité j'allais dire aléatoire et
moi je suis très heureuse parce que ça
fait un petit moment que je demande
qu'on puisse procéder à ces contrôles
d'identité dans lequel dans le dans les
transports en commun donc aujourd'hui il
faut pour prendre les transports en
commun pouvoir justifier de son identité
vous savez que c'est la loi savary qui
devrait être promulguée dans les jours
qui viennent
nous attendons vraiment que le présent
la république la première est vite et
que les décrets d'application de cette
loi soit pris très vite salée que j'ai
moi même beaucoup plus vrai pour que
cette loi oil jours et je crois que
c'est très important pour la sécurité de
tous vous voulez qu'elle s'applique
maintenant on écoute la réaction aux
attentats de ce matin de nicolas sarkozy
qui réclame une action mais c'est ici
d'effroi une nouvelle fois par la
brutalité la sauvagerie la barbarie de
ces attentats si peu de temps après
cette arrestation
je vous dire toute mon émotion pour les
victimes pour leur famille et toute ma
solidarité avec le gouvernement belge et
autorités belges le peuple belge frappé
aujourd'hui hier c'était abidjan la côte
d'ivoire avant dire c'était la turquie
bref personne n'est à l'abri ça va
demander une prise de conscience quant à
la fermeté de notre réponse extrêmement
limpides
cette prise de conscience quant à la
fermeté nécessaire aujourd'hui pour
répondre vous l'avez senti auprès des
autorités de de l'exécutif aujourd'hui
oui mais vous voyez quand j'apprends à
ma grande stupéfaction cet après midi
que le fichier qu'on l'appelle le
personal name ricort de vieux fichiers
des déplacements en avion en europe mais
toujours pas mis en place parce que les
députés européens n'ont pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord je me dis mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cet aveuglement comment
est-ce qu'on peut après le 13 novembre
et pas des compressions il ya bernard
cazeneuve réclame avec force ce vote ans
ont été décalés dans le temps ce bien
sûr mais là aussi j'appelle à la
responsabilité
on sait que si celui-ci ce fichier n'a
pas été approuvé c'est parce que il ya
eu une espèce d'alliance contre nature
du front national et j'allais dire des
populistes européens avec une partie de
la gauche l'antique on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui même si on certains pays
n'ont pas été frappés ils doivent être
solidaires de ceux qui le sont
aujourd'hui
et là vraiment je pousse un cri enfin
l'europe pourra réagir
on peut pas être un ventre mou sinon
c'est toute l'europe à se désagréger
peut pas être un ventre mou face à la
menace terroriste
on doit être souverain souverain ça veut
dire prendre au parlement européen les
vraies décisions il n'y a pas que les
parlements français belge parce que
sinon ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on va vers le retour des frontières
ça veut dire qu'on va vers la
dislocation de l'europe déjà un peu le
cas aujourd'hui en tous les cas le
retour des frontières il y à un scénario
catastrophe dans lequel l'europe ne
survit pas à une crise terroristes qui
met à l'épreuve sa fermeté et sa
capacité à être souveraine
et à avoir des frontières sûres c'est un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui à vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui on a commis un bon nous
de porte d'entrée avec la belgique c'est
énorme
donc la question des frontières
européennes et de la et la puissance de
la réponse européenne est aussi en cause
alors on écoute françois hollande qui a
pris la parole solennellement également
ce matin pour appeler à l'unité nous
devons veiller plus que jamais à notre
unité
je parle de l'unité au plan européen
je pourrais également par les unités au
plan mondial pour les pays qui veulent
agir contre le terrorisme mais l'unité
la plus indispensable
elle est au plan national en la l'unité
vous êtes d'accord avec d'un sur sept
unités mais entraîner en contrepartie
d'actions moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
l'action oui l'unité pour l'action parce
que on peut pas rester passif face à
cette menace et moi j'ai beaucoup
apprécié la démarche de bernard
cazeneuve je l'appelais pour dire qu'est
ce que je peux faire de plus
il m'a tout de suite dit venez on va en
parler et on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
de plus ensemble
je pense que l'unité c'est pour l'action
c'est pas uniquement pour des postures
ou pour ceux où voilà où pour se mettre
en valeur et b si la droite est au
pouvoir par exemple ce que les choses
seraient différentes il ya une phrase
c'est terrible de marion maréchal-le pen
qui a dit que les lieux accueillent
d'attentât en france le 13 novembre si
le front national était au pouvoir avait
été au pouvoir comme si on avait réagi à
ce point et puisque la droite ferait
différemment les choses
d'abord c'est une phrase totalement
grotesque c'est à l'état elle d'autant
plus grotesque que je vous dis le front
national a refusé de voter le personnel
emery cote
le front national a refusé de voter la
loi renseignement le fonds national a
refusé l'interdiction des sites qui
appelle à l' aile sur internet au nom de
la liberté de pouvoir dire ce qu'on veut
sur internet liberté qu'ils utilisent
abondamment donc la vérité c'est que
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont dans l'action
c'est les partis de gouvernement parce
que c'est ceux qui sont responsables
alors si vous me demandez si je pense qu
on a perdu un peu de temps oui j'ai
trouvé qu'on avait perdu du temps on a
perdu du temps sur la sécurité dans les
transports
moi ça fait des
mois et des mois que j'alerte est et on
me disait où vous êtes en campagne
électorale
bon et maintenant il ya une unité et une
unanimité que je dois saluer et c'est
précieux cette unité dans les moments
que nous vivons est donc je ne
critiquerai rien aujourd'hui même si je
vous dis dès janvier 2015
j'avais alerté j'avais demandé qu'on
travaille à un patriot act à la
française ça on a perdu du temps mais
aujourd'hui l'unité que que nous vivons
est trop précieuse pour compte
pollinisation est ce qu'on a perdu du
temps également dans certains
territoires de la république et
notamment d'île de france selon google
et répèterai c' est ce qu'il y a des
mullen bec aux portes de paris
je crois que la situation mais je n'ai
pas la nôtre d'abord parce que nous
avons aujourd'hui en tout cas je
l'espère vraiment pris la mesure du
danger qui nous menace et nous avons une
action qui aujourd'hui de 2,2 on a fermé
des mosquées des mosquées qui appelait à
la haine on en a fermé en ile de france
on a fermé la mosquée de lagny sur marne
seine et marne il ya toujours le
deuxième sommet communautarisme
salafistes vous l'avez dénoncé durant
votre campagne
oui moi ce que je crois c'est que aucune
capitale européenne et la france
l'île de france est une capitale très
cosmopolite aucune capitale européenne
n'est à l'abri de foyers de
radicalisation nous avons en ligne de
france des foyers de radicalisation nous
le savons et nous devons lutter contre
et nous devons lutter contre alors
j'allais dire ça mais l'éditeur est ce
que vous vous adressez à certaine
complaisance politique dans certaines
municipalités par exemple on a pu
peut-être par lâcheté ou naïveté fermer
les yeux et il y en a certainement eu de
la lâcheté dabo aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
dans certaines villes bah écoutez moi je
vais vous donner un seul exemple c'est
un petit exemple et pour moi il est il
très symbolique je suis une femme vous
comprendrez que c'est pour moi
symbolique le fait qu' on puisse
aujourd'hui à voir des femmes en voile
intégral sur le sol de 2 de l'île de
france dans des banlieues
c'est un signe de provocation c'est le
premier signe il est totalement visible
l'unesco de ratification de la loi
je ne réclame pas seulement ça la prime
sur la loi ou d'abord je réclame
l'application la loi mais ça c'est le
minimum entre les niveaux mais surtout
qu'on mette n'ai pu me dire que j'ai pu
lire y compris dans la presse parce que
c'était les cinq ans d'interdiction ou
les dix ans les cinq ans l'interdiction
de la burqa sur le sol
le seul français que j'ai pu lire que ce
n'était pas un sujet alors que c'est un
signe visible extérieure d'un début de
radicalisation ada début de coupure
vis-à-vis du fai républicain donc en
réalité au lieu de prendre ce voile
intégral pour ce qu'il est c'est à dire
une forme de dérive dans laquelle on
estime que la loi de sa religion est
plus forte que la loi de son pays parce
que c'est ça parce que ça traduit et
bien au lieu de prendre ça comme un
signal d'alarmé
on a fermé les yeux on a détourné la
tête et on n'a pas voulu voir
oui il ya eu de la lâcheté il ya eu la
lâcheté il y en a encore
et il faut pas aujourd'hui vous avez
mené l'action là sur ce terrain là moi
je vais vous dire des choses là mais moi
je pense je crois qu'une partie de mon
élection en décembre vient du fait que
j'ai dit un certain nombre de choses que
je serai mieux public est intransigeant
que je couperai toutes les subventions
régionales aux associations dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de respect des
principes de la république de la laïcité
de l'égalité hommes femmes que j'ai dit
que nous irions vérifier dans les
sociétés de transport mais aussi dans
les services publics qui dépendent de
l'argent qu'il n'y a pas de personnes en
voie de radicalisation au contact des
usagers au contact dans les sociétés
transport dans les lycées donc tout ce
que j'ai dit dans la campagne je pense à
mettre en oeuvre on le met en oeuvre on
est en train de travailler sur une
charte de la laïcité pour toutes les
associations subventionnées par la
région parce que nous avons un problème
nous avons un problème de laïcité un
certain nombre d'associations sportives
d'un problème de laïcité dans un certain
nombre d'établissements scolaires où il
ya des pressions à la fois
communautariste et j'allais dire
intégrer est-ce que vous voterez la
pétition lancée par jean-françois copé
contre l'article 6 de la loi elle
conneries sur la liberté religieuse
au travail moi j y ait débat sur
l'impact de cette mesure
je vais vous dire ce que j'en pense oui
j'ai lu cet article avec attention
je ne comprends pas quel est son objet
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est des limites justement
disent ses auteurs alors l'article en
réalité si je leur ai dit viens moi qui
éclairait robond fonctionnement de
l'entreprise telles que je les compris
enfin d'après ce que j'ai lu
mais vous me corrigerez puisque vous
l'avez peut-être sous les yeux il dit la
liberté religieuse existe dans
l'entreprise on a le droit de manifester
son appartenance religieuse dans
l'entreprise sauf si ça met en péril
l'organiser l'organisation de la demande
de l'entreprise vous voyez là que la
façon dont la chose est posée pose
d'abord le principe prestations et son
engagement au communautarisme religieux
je trouve que je ne vois pas l'intérêt
de rappeler ce qui est aujourd'hui
j'entends votre réelle parce que la
compétition
nassir laissez moi finir de m'expliquer
je ne vois pas l'intérêt aujourd'hui de
réaffirmer une liberté qui existe
enfin si le principe c'est de dire ce
qui existe c'est à dire qu'il ya une
liberté en france de manifester sa
religion qui a comme limite le fait de
ne pas nuire au bon fonctionnement
l'entreprise c'est j'allais dire à la
limite partout banon met en revanche en
revanche ce que je crains c'est
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il nous demande
les entreprises en ile de france
elles nous demandent de pouvoir faire
des chars de la laïcité elle nous
demande au contraire de pouvoir fixer
leur ticket malvenu selon vos bas
j'espère qu'il n'est pas trop de
munitions pillée pardon qui peut envoyer
un contre message c'est à dire les
entreprises ont sont les entreprises
aujourd'hui elles ne savent plus ce
qu'elles ont droit de faire et ce
qu'elles n'ont pas le droit de faire et
je peux vous le dire parce que j'étais
l'autre jour sur la plate forme de
roissy
vous savez que la plate forme de roissy
c'est ca vrai un bail au porteur c'est
un vrai enjeu de sécurité et c'est aussi
des milliers de personnes qui
travaillent dans un certain nombre sont
issus de du territoire de la
seine-saint-denis et donc on a
aujourd'hui besoin d'être sûrs que
personne dans sur cette zone
aéroportuaire néant risque de
radicalisation les entreprises qu'est ce
qu'elles demandent
elles demandent de pouvoir faire des
chars de la laïcité pour vérifier que
tous les personnels et sur l'article 6
voulais pas me dire si vous les pieds de
signer cette pétition
moi je lisais ce genre de sillonner moi
j'ai moi je suis pas très signature de
la question d'une lumière généralement
je pense je pense qu'il ya une forme de
phase iib mal venu de dire aujourd'hui
que le dire aujourd'hui des choses
ambigu sur le sujet mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le sujet c est ce que les
entreprises peuvent mettre en place des
chartes de la laïcité
chez ont brûlé dans la région et ma
réponse c'est évidemment oui quand dans
l'entreprise à ce salarié ne serre pas
la main une autre d'une autre d'une
d'une de ses consoeurs quand un
conducteur de bus refuse de prendre son
service
après une femme et ses cd comportant qui
alerte
on a des signal dallaire la déchéance de
nationalité maintenant obligée elle a du
plomb dans l aile vous avez vu après le
vote ya quelques instants du sénat qui a
réécrit le texte issu du compromis
laborieux de l'assemblée nationale entre
la droite et la gauche
est ce que vous le regrettez est acquis
la raison la faute de ce fiasco selon
vous ma position est simple je ne suis
plus dépouillé donc je ne voterai pas
mais ma position est simple je pense que
ce texte n'a pas sa place dans la
constitution la déchéance de nationalité
n'a pas sa place dans la constitution
pourquoi parce que je suis favorable à
des sanctions exemplaires contre le
terrorisme mais dans la constitution qui
est notre loi fondamentale qu'on puisse
faire la distinction entre deux types de
français ça me choque d'accord alors en
tous les cas
manuel valls le premier ministre ne se
décourage pas il veut poursuivre la
discussion en écoute les français
attendent de nous exige de nous le
rassemblement
ils ne comprendraient pas je le dis très
sincèrement ils ne comprendraient pas
que l'assemblée nationale et le sénat la
majorité et l'opposition ne puisse pas
se mettre d'accord sur ce qui fonde
notre pacte républicain et national
alors après ce temps bree imbroglio sur
la déchéance de nationalité les
sénateurs les républicains ont proposé
de décider d'une peine de prison
perpétuelle la perpétuité perpétuel et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
sans possibilité de remise est ce que
c'est une idée qui vous agréent toute la
pétition pense par exemple à sale
abdeslam de toutes les façons il ya des
peines aujourd'hui de sûreté de
rétention si une personne qui est
condamné à la perpétuité aujourd'hui
c'est à dire à 20-30 ans de prison ferme
aujourd'hui au moment où il sort s'il
est encore dangereux
oui il ya des rétention de sûreté donc
deux fois ne doit pas sortir mais pas
question de laisser salir n'existe pas
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du terrorisme
et d'ailleurs manuel valls a dit il ya
quelques instants qu'il était prêt à
étudier cette proposition venue de la
droite on peut tout étudier mais d'une
manière générale je pense qu'il ne faut
pas laisser sortir un terroriste de
prison il faut le retenir
avec une peine de rétention de sûreté
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il
y à un certain nombre de personnes qui
ne se sont pas du tout amendé en prison
et donc il faut quand même qu'on
applique la loi telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui avec de la rétention de
sûreté
parce que la peine que le sénat va
pourrir proposée elle ne s'appliquera
qu'à l'avenir
c'est là qu'elle s'appliquera que pour
le futur moi je pense à ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui en prison
je pense à ces foyers de radicalisation
alors là pour le coup si vous voulez
qu'on ensyta en ile de france info une
radicalisation c'est les prisons ile de
france
on le sait est donc on a un sujet c'est
une attention à la voile à ne pas
laisser sortir de prison des criminels à
la fin de leur peine sans vérifier
qu'ils ne sont pas dangereux à les
deuxièmes parties de preuves par 3
maintenant valérie pécresse on va
évoquer votre action à la tête de la
région ile-de-france dans d'autres
sujets d'autres domaines voxan jours
après votre élection quels objectifs
vous fixez vous en matière d'emploi vous
voulez mettre en place des formations
avec l'aide de l'état d'ailleurs comme
d'autres présidents les républicains
mais cela ne désarme pas votre
opposition socialiste bien au contraire
ainsi un opposition incarnée par luc
carvounas écoutez vous allez pouvoir
réagir car il tient des propos on va
dire assez aiguisées j'entends ce que
vous me dites qu'il est prête à
collaborer tant mieux je vous aussi des
propositions qu'elle fait pour les tpe
les pme pour la formation
bon il me fait un peu l'impression
d'être là ravi de la crèche 1 valérie
pécresse ans
yves pas complètement nue dans cette
région ile de france qui est la première
région d'europe et qui a montré sur la
compétitivité avec les grandes
entreprises des choses extrêmement
qualitative et puis si c'est donner des
aides aux pme et aux tpe pour enlever
comme elle le fait pour des communes
comme un fort ville dont je suis le
maire l'aide à la pierre pour enlever
pour des communes comme alfortville dont
je suis maire l'aide à des structures
dont le siège est à la formule pour
l'heure 15 national d'île de france
en gros c'est déshabiller paul pour
habiller jacques et faire semblant qu'on
travaille pour tous
écoutez moi je le dénonceraient comme
j'ai commencé à le faire sur la question
du logement social
valérie pécresse elle la politique
politicienne nous annonce même qu'elle
va nous acheter 7 100 rames nouvelle
pour le rer en augmentant les tarifs du
stif valérie pécresse c'est la plus
grande hypocrisie qui soit et je pense
que les franciliens ont vite s'en rendre
compte
voilà on a l'impression que la campagne
se poursuivre propos recueillis par
marie brémaud bonsoir mais qu'elle va
mettre israël poursuit valérie pécresse
a alors il faut peut être déjà que vous
répondiez à lui carvounas mais si on
comprend bien ce qui a été fait pour 17
ans était de la gamme j ai avec vous
tout va changer
c'est bien ça d'abord j'ai envie de dire
à luc carvounas que la campagne est
terminée et que les électeurs ont
tranché et ils ont tranché parce qu'ils
ont le sentiment qu effectivement avec
moi tout allait changer et je vous le
dis effectivement tout va changer
tout va changer c'est à dire la tma
changé par la gabegie pas du tout pas du
tout si vous avez regardé mais mon
budget leur audience m
c'est un budget de relance par
l'investissement et là effectivement
tout change
parce que le problème aujourd'hui de la
région ile de france c'est que depuis 17
ans les dépenses de fonctionnement n'ont
fait qu'augmenter tous les ans et les
dépenses d'investissement
au contraire en proportion ont baissé
tous les ans donc le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il faut réinvestir en plus nous
avions un budget qui était fictif
figurez vous parce que la région nous
disait on investit un milliard dans les
transports le lendemain du vote du
budget voté à un milliard d'euros pour
les transports il y avait un gel on
annulait 500 millions donc en réalité le
budget était fictif donc excusez moi de
vous dire que ce genre de pratique
n'honore pas la politique et que
j'habite luc carvounas à lire l'audit
que nous allons faire des comptes de la
région et qui sera publié
ça lui apprendra peut-être effectivement
ce n'était pas bien seulement quelques
17 un chiffre qui a dit quoi de ces 17
en place non le sujet aujourd'hui il est
simple il y avait un pass navigo à tarif
unique qui a été mis en place à 70 euros
qui n'étaient pas financés
il manquait 300 millions d'euros je les
dis pendant toute la campagne pour y
arriver je suis arrivé et on m'a dit ah
ben les 300 millions il faut couper la
formation professionnelle il faut
arrêter la modernisation des transports
parce que la région doit payer j'ai dit
mais je ne payerai pas je vais aller
voir monsieur valls et je vais le mettre
devant ces responsables de leur finale
et bien alors nous avons sauvé pour un
nom pour un an le pass navigo pour 2016
parce que j'ai pris un certain nombre de
décisions de lutte contre la fraude de
suppression des 75 % de réduction pour
les étrangers en situation irrégulière
ce a coûté 40 millions à la région
et puis nous avons obtenu de l'état
l'annulation d'une d'une créance fiscale
sur le syndicat des transports mais ça
n'est que temporaire et j'ai un
engagement aujourd'hui du premier
ministre de me transférer une recette
fiscales pérennes de l'état pour
maintenir se passe et vous rendez compte
de l'impasse financière que j'ai trouvé
il me manquait 300 millions pour le pass
navigo qui avait été jeté une décision
purement électorales de la gauche ans
été réalisés nous on vous a mis 45 euros
de moins sur le pass et puis j'avais 140
millions de baisses de dotations
globales rend vous étiez aux affaires
vous avez aussi 440 minutes vous avez
d'autres engagements vis-à-vis des
électeurs puisque pendant la campagne
vous avez dit vous ne vouliez pas peser
sur leur pouvoir d'achat alors est-ce
que vous allez éventuellement augmenter
le montant du passe à nos noms la
josiane nuit pour dénommer la meba
lalala le budget sera voté dans deux
semaines le pass navigo est maintenu à
60 à 70 euros grâce
grâce à l'effort qu'a fait si les glaces
ben non pas merci manuel valls merci
manuel valls d'avoir accepté de
reconnaître qu'il était responsable de
cette décision électorale non film et
vous laisser la porte ouverte pour 2017
au lycée 2017 2010 est gênant
engagement écrit du premier ministre à
trouver une ressource fiscale pérenne
pour la région pour maintenir ce pass
est donc moi je ne pourrais parisien
lieu pour ces lieux qui nous regarde pas
trop en tout cas pour une année j'ai
réussi à équilibrer un budget qui au
départ était totalement déséquilibré
quand je suis arrivé et au delà de ça
moi j'ai trouvé une situation qui était
en réalité
j'allais dire de non-gestion j'ai tenu
une conférence pour le l'emploi lundi et
je me suis aperçu que l'île de france
était la seule région celle régions dans
lesquelles nous n'avons pas
d'informations par bassin d'emploi sur
les métiers en tension et sur les
formations nécessaires sur ces métiers
nous sommes je crois aussi l'une des
seules régions
nous finançons 600 millions d'euros de
formation nous n'avons pas de contrat de
performance c'est à dire que quand je
finance à 100 de l'apprentissage un
centre de formation je n'ai pas le
nombre de places vacantes
s'il est rempli ou pas remplies je n'ai
pas s'il ya des débouchés
je n'ai pas si le taux de rupture le
taux d'échec au taux de réussite donc
j'ai mis en place un contrat de
performance
il nous faut des indicateurs la vérité
c'est que cette région était très riche
elle est très très puissant oui mais
elle était surtout pas bien gérer votre
argent parce que c'est votre argent vous
êtes des franciliens l'argent de vos
impôts n'étaient pas bien utilisé
est-ce que je peux pas revenir sur la
formation la droite où ils savaient très
bien et vos amis à droite disent que le
plan de formation voulue par console en
effet pour masquer les chiffres du
chômage nation vous vous inscrivez aussi
dans ses propos il est fait évidemment
alors qu'ailleurs vous venez de dire que
vous étiez prêts à faire un plan sur la
formation en attendait mais je suis paré
club de l'état je pense qu'à une
priorité une urgence sociale en
ile-de-france qui est de l'emploi
et j'ajoute même quand ils le font c'est
très particulier parce que nous avons un
marché de l'emploi qui est complètement
duale c'est dire que nous avons un
marché de l'emploi qualifié qui
globalement un marché qui fonctionne
bien c'est à dire quand on est qualifiés
en ile de france on a une chance de
retrouver assez vite de l'emploi pour
tous et puis on a vu qu'ils ne sont pas
pourvus et puis on a aussi à marcher des
des travailleurs non qualifiés et ce
marché là est un marché en déshérence en
désespérance parce que avec la osé
charge la hausse de la fiscalité sur les
entreprises
eh bien on a désindustrialisé une de
france on a fait disparaître toutes un
volant d'emplois non qualifiés et là on
a du chômage de très longue durée avec
des taux pour les jeunes dans certains
cas
et qui sont très près donc est ce que
vous allez appliquée mallard du
gouvernement sur moi je suis prête à
faire davantage pour la formation bien
entendu qu'elle président de région
pourrait vous dire non simplement je
ferai du qualitatif
moi je ne suis pas tenu par l'agenda de
monsieur hollande moi je ne suis pas là
pour faire inverser la courbe du chômage
avant le 31 décembre pour pouvoir me
présenter à la présidence
non mais moi mon sujet c'est pas ça je
ne peux pas moralement je ne peux pas
moralement inscrire dans des formations
sans débouchés des des personnes qui
cherchent un emploi
aujourd'hui ce que je vais faire j'ai
déjà identifié quatre types de formation
que je peux un exemple évident
premièrement les fondamentaux parce que
là aussi il faut briser les tabous moi
je briserai tous les tabous je dirai les
choses l'accès la maîtrise de la langue
française
l'illettrisme le fait de ne pas
maîtriser les quatre opérations les
savoirs de base en sciences l'anglais
sont la bureautique
il ya des fondamentaux à connaître pour
pouvoir être employables on a
aujourd'hui besoin de remise à niveau
nous ferons des formations de remise à
niveau il y a aussi les métiers en
tension
nous allons d'ici juin identifier les
dix messi qui est en tension dans 25
bassins d'emploi et nous aurons des
formations supplémentaires par exemple
poser de la fibre optique par exemple
community manager pour des sites web par
exemple les priorités des wii en
ile-de-france alors oui ou des métiers
de la sécurité ou des métiers de service
à laquelle vous a donné un objectif
chiffré que nous allons assumer reprend
alors on est l'autre ans et on a une
troisième priorité nation c'est
important c'est qu'on a des personnes
qui sont prêts recruté par l'entreprise
et puis entreprises se rend compte qu'il
leur manque aller 2-3 mois de formation
un peu plus concrète de préparation
alors vouloir se messieurs nous allons
les financer
alors oui nous avons commencé à chiffrer
mes objectifs et je n'ai pas encore le
nom de glomel ccc l'attique peut-être
qu'on sera en désaccord avec est à
l'étape de monde
soixante quatre mille personnes en
formation moi je pense que ce chiffre on
six mois est totalement déraisonnable
vous vous de soral et mètres dans des
formations parking
donc moi ce que je veux c'est vraiment
que les personnes que je vais m en
formation je veux que vraiment derrière
on puisse leur proposer un débouché et
que ce soit vraiment un parent au
lendemain à vos conditions
voilà le qualitatif on va faire du
qualitatif
on va vraiment travailler sur les
besoins des entreprises et du marché de
l'emploi l'état va vous donnez combien
pour sa d'écouter ce sera trois mille
euros par personne que je formerai sur
un budget ça peut valoir millions
d'euros c'est bien ça abba en millions
d'euros ça peut ça peut aller jusqu'à
200 millions de vos biens mais là encore
moi je suis très perplexe parce que cet
argent va me le donner pour cette année
mais ça veut dire qu'on aime le coupé
l'année prochaine ça veut dire que je
vais tenir ses engagements écrits non
dans la façon dont l'état le propose
c'est juste pour 2017
excusez moi ça fait c'est ça c'est que
l'état gère jusqu'en 2017 et après plus
rien oui alors moi par exemple vous
pouvez me dire
ouvrez une école de la deuxième chance
aujourd'hui voit des écoles de la
deuxième chance page voudrait augmenter
et capacité des écoles de la deuxième
chance pour les jeunes décrocheurs
mais si j'en crée une nouvelle je peux
pas la créer pour un en double il a créé
sur la durée donc qui va financer
l'année d'après donc vous voyez il ya
plein de questions auxquelles je n'ai
pas encore de réponse je suis allé voir
le préfet de région
je veux qu'ils m'expliquent mais pour
l'instant j'ai plutôt l'impression que
si vous voulez c'est une bulle d'oxygène
mais attention parce que quand elle aura
explosé non on aura besoin on sera
encore là et qu'elle va mais monsieur
hollande il sera peut-être plus mais
nous on sera encore là vous avez cassé
nerf de la guerre vous savez très bien
c'est aussi l'argent et ce sont les
fonctionnaires territoriaux
avez vous calculez combien va vous
coûter l'augmentation du point d'indicé
des fonctionnaires alors oui
malheureusement ça va nous coûter
sans doute alors ça va se mettre en
place progressivement à dire
gouvernement donc j'ai pas tous les
détails mais au minimum un million
d'euros cette année et l'année prochaine
3 millions d'euros on vous financez ça
et bien évidemment le problème c'est que
moi je n'ai plus d'argent donc le
problème c'est qu'on va être obligé de
faire des deux ans qu'on connaît mais
encore plus attention à nos recrutements
des économies encore plus être dans les
recrutements
c'est à dire on va développer deux là on
va on va en moi je vais maîtriser ma
masse salariale ça veut dire
vous serez certainement avec soyez
prêtes à emprunter a maintenant on ne
peut pas emprunter pour financer le
fonctionnement ça c'est interdit clooney
et j'ajoute que la région ile-de-france
petit incident pour monsieur cardona à
augmenter son endettement de 3 milliards
sur dix ans donc aujourd'hui on n'a plus
la capacité d'emprunter parce que vous
allez demander des efforts aux
fonctionnaires alors peut-être qu'il me
ceux qui partiront à la retraite ne
seront pas tous remplacés c'est un peu
le problème national qui défend françois
fillon notamment et est ce que vous
allez leur demander des efforts en
termes horaire par exemple alors moins
d'envié plus d'abord j'ai sanctuariser
les personnels des lycées parce que ce
qui est très étonnant c'est la façon
dont la précédente majorité de gauche
allait gérer la région
ils ont baissé d'un pour cent les
effectifs des lycées alors qu'on a
besoin on vous savez que je gère les
personnes qui font l'entretien les
personnes qui font la surveillance les
personnes qui font la cantine du lycée
donc leurs effectifs avaient baissé de
-1 1% mais en revanche les effectifs du
siège ont augmenté de 9%
donc ce que je vais faire ses jeux faire
l' inverse je sens que tu arrives des
effectifs des lycées dans lesquels on a
des gros besoins et je vais faire
baisser les effectifs du siège et j'y ai
pensé sur le nombre d'heures
supplémentaires
attendez j'ai déjà suscité des jalousies
des attendait pas non mais j'ai déjà
annoncé que je ne remplacerai aucun
départ à la retraite au siège moi c'est
pas un dégoût d'eux c'est aucun oui il
reste deux petites questions très court
nous aviez promis les tests salivaires à
l'entrée des lycées pour contrôler sur
le cannabis vous en êtes où alors c'est
pas du tout ce que j'avais dit ce que
j'ai dit c'est que je financerai ces
tests et qu'il faisait partie d'une
batterie d'outils que j'allais mettre à
la disposition des proviseurs dans le
cadre de plans détaillés
oui bien sûr des plans d'établissement
de lutte contre les addictions et
décrochage scolaire parce que en
ile-de-france est là aussi
allez on va dire les choses le
décrochage scolaire et les addictions
sur peuvent être étroitement liés donc
je vais demander à tous les proviseurs
d'ile-de-france de me présenter un plan
de lutte contre les addictions et le
décrochage scolaire
chacun prendra dans la batterie les
outils qui ne suis qu il le voudra ça
peut être de la vidéo protection contre
les dealers ça peut être de temps en
temps un passage de forces de sécurité
police municipale ou police nationale
pour contrôler
d entrée aux portes des lycées ça peut
des tests salivaires qui permettent de
savoir donc c'est mieux mais ça sera
mise en place à la moi moi je proposerai
la batterie d'outils et ce que j'ai dit
aux proviseurs et moi ceux ci souhaitent
faire des études la région financera ils
financeront aussi et c'est très
important pour moi
des référents addictions et lutte contre
le décrochage dans les lycées ou pas
votre déménagement seine-saint-denis le
déménagement de la meute sièges allégés
en personnel en la ville de free et le
processus est en cours nous avons déjà
visité 35 sites et la semaine que la
france la semaine prochaine nous
adoptons avec les agents parce que
évidemment c'est une démarche dans
laquelle les agents sont très associé
vous savez c'est pas facile de quitter
le 7e arrondissement de paris donc nous
adopterons le 29 mars
la grille des critères qui nous
permettra de désigner les six nuls oui
les cris tabac d'autres innovations je
n'ai visité que j'ai dit la délibération
c'est de l'autre côté du périphérique
mais comme c'est plus équilibré à l'est
j'ai déjà prévenu les hauts-de-seine que
je ne serai pas chez eux
donc voila merci beaucoup mais klm s on
attendra le résultat de vos différents
des visites troisième partie de preuves
par 3 maintenant avec nadège peljak de
l' agence france-presse
on va parler des primaires de la droite
1 de la droite seule désormais et de
votre champion enfin vous allez pouvoir
nous le confirmer ou pas françois fillon
qui estime être le seul aujourd'hui à
proposer un programme radical il n'est
pas du tout arrêté par les mauvais
sondages aucune importance ces sondages
ce sont des sondages très étrange ce
sont des sondages qui concerne une
élection dont on ne connaît pas les
candidats dont on ne connaît pas les
programmes et dont on ne connaît pas les
électeurs
les sondeurs font des sondages sur quel
sur un objet qui n'existe pas dans
l'esprit des français
regardez les son gala regardez il ya au
fond des programmes coups de menton il
ya des programmes pépère y avait presque
un shooting
voilà les programmes pépère casting ou
coups de menton défini par françois
fillon mais avant de parler de lune a
déjoué jake bon savoir
candidat aux primaires ont prises avec
la justice un oui on va parler enfin aux
prises ne sera peut-être de monsieur
sarkozy l'ancien président donc cet
après midi la cour de cassation a validé
les écoutes téléphoniques dans les
enquêtes ou monsieur sarkozy justement
est mis en examen pour corruption
bon on s'y attendait c'est pas une
surprise enfin l'ancien président
pourrait se retrouver dans un tribunal
correctionnel là aussi c'est pas sûr
mais et c'est peut-être quand même si
c'était le cas ce qui pourrait
participer à une primaire
vous savez moi je crois à la présomption
d'innocence et je pense qu'il ya des
procédures judiciaires en cours et que
je n'ai pas à les commenter
et après il ya des décisions
individuelles un certain nombre d'hommes
d'hommes politiques qui souhaite ou pas
se présenter
moi vous savez je pense que chacun est
légitime à se présenter ça vous choque
c'est pas si par exemple ils étaient
amenés à comparaître devant un tribunal
correctionnel qui soit également
candidat à la primaire ça me choquerait
pas mal c'est évident que cela
affaiblira sa affaiblira sa candidature
et ses sens c'est une évidence
maintenant le sujet c'est il faut que
les français aient le choix et il faut
qu'ils se déterminent librement et cette
primaire est un très bel exercice
démocratique parce que ça va nous
permettre de parler projets et moi
j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient plus de
projets que deux candidats madame pull
back et j'aimerais bien que
effectivement pas possible et plus de
progrès plus de candidats pour avoir par
des crises et moi je me suis mal exprimé
c'est la fatigue et les émotions des
attentats aujourd'hui il ya plus de plus
d'idées plus d'idées que deux candidats
voilà qu'on parle plus des projets que
des candidats pour le reformuler parce
que c'est un peu ce qui me tracasse
depuis des semaines on parle beaucoup de
ces primaires c'est peut-être un peu
prématuré quand même
mais au lieu de parler de la
présidentielle par une entrée qui serait
quelles réformes
comment rétablir l'autorité dans notre
pays comment simplifier ce semi quand il
ya une estrade sept ans chela sur la
question est sur toutes ces questions
d'ailleurs oui enfin il son droit
s'cusez moi excusez moi de dire que je
je je je verrai je vais tirer un coup de
chapeau à françois fillon qui n'est pas
mon candidat il ya entre parenthèses
monsieur grossir puisque j'ai dit que je
n'avais pas de candidat puisque l
automne et que je me déterminerai au vu
à la fois
enfin au vu des réponses que les
candidats apporterons un certain nombre
de 10 dès que je poserai moi-même sur la
table parce qu'il ya un moment mon
expérience de présidente de région me
fait voir beaucoup de choses que ce soit
sur les domaines de l'autorité et de la
république on en a parlé aujourd'hui où
la laïcité mais aussi dans le domaine de
l'emploi dans le domaine de la
simplification administrative dans le
domaine de la réforme que je suis en
train de mener et j'espère qu'on ira
jusqu'au bout
mais le sujet le sujet c'est que
vont-ils proposées et c'est là dessus
qu'ils aient que à mon avis les français
se décideront les je suis d'accord avec
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure les
sondages aujourd'hui ne veulent
strictement rien dire rien ces questions
sont et ségolène royal sont enfin en
souvenez vous de dominique strauss kahn
ségolène royal et laurent fabius qui
aurait misé sur ségolène royal
la vérité c'est que quand vous avez un
programme qui est en phase avec les
attentes du pays
c'est vous qui remporté la primaire et
la primaire elle se joue alors dans les
causes et un volet guerlain jourdan dans
tous les candidats qui actuellement sont
déjà déclarés et ceux qui ne le sont pas
d'ailleurs je pense à mes jeux sarkozy
et ils ont annoncé la couleur déjà et
nous ont présenté leur projet ou en tous
les cas des parties importantes de leurs
projets bah écoutez je les ai lu moi
c'est parti là vous avez bien dû les
lire également
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez ils
ont déjà proposé des choses monsieur
fillon ne dit j'ai un programme le plus
radical qui soit c'est possible
puisqu'il le dit vous avez bien lu son
programme à fillon a pris a pris de
l'avancé
moi personnellement je trouve que vous
avez de l'avant position il a pris de
l'avancé notamment sur tout le volet ben
ça arrive à bompas des jeunes qui est
économie
tendai l'éducatif si moi je trouve qu'il
ya déjà des choses qui sont
intéressantes dans son programme mais
j'attends de voir les programmes des
autres et moi même je vais apporter ma
pierre parce qu'un certain nombre de
sujets n'ont pas encore été traités
notamment le rapport au territoire
notamment le choc de simplification le
vrai celui tous les français attendent
pour pouvoir agir parce que ce que je
vois sur le terrain en ile de france
c'est une formidable vitalité
on a de l'entrepreneuriat dans les
quartiers on a des start up on a du high
tech on a des chercheurs magnifique on
l'a on a un potentiel d'action on a des
associations ont là un potentiel
d'action qui vient du terrain et qui est
totalement boidé par un système sûr
administrés nébuleux kafkaïen les deux
camps il date ce système est recueillir
mais il s'est laissé maintenant mais
c'est un empilement madame paul jackson
un pin on n'a jamais rien à retirer nos
qu'à un moment donné faut faire table
rase du passé et j'allais vous dire il
ya des réformes qui en réalité
l'inspiration ne sont plus ni de droite
ni de gauche mais elles sont la
frontière c'est entre le courage de dire
la vérité et de faire et j'allais dire
le laisser-aller une certaine forme de
lâcheté une certaine heure de jeu ça
mais justement dans mes chansons c'est
peut-être la recomposition avant avant
avant de parler de recomposition moi je
crache sauvagement soient de droite ou
grossiord est ce que je vois aujourd'hui
la loi les conneries et je vois le
gouvernement reculer reculer recul et
donc je me dis il y avait peut-être des
réformateurs au gouvernement mais ils
sont finalement que cacher sous la table
vous voyez donc la vérité c'est qu'il ya
certainement quelques réformateur moi
quand j'entends emmanuel macron dire
fois contrat de travail unique et que je
le vois à la fin taxer les cdd
je voulais je me dis bon ben voilà il ya
deux macron oui donc ou alors le
gouvernement a détourné sa pensée le
sujet c'est que quand on entend certains
au gouvernement on al impression qu
effectivement les réformes sont ni
droite ni gauche
au final quand on voit l'action du
gouvernement on se dit que peut-être
vivement la droite pour faire enfin les
réformes
moi j'aurais revenir à la primaire vous
avez vu que ce week end les centristes
se sont réunis entre eux ils ont décidé
bien nous voilà on n'y va pas la
primaire on nous parlait d'une prière de
la droite et du centre
exit le centre ya plus que la droite
maintenant
est-ce que ça affaiblit processus avec
moi je crois que c'est une terriblement
mauvaise décision mais je ne perds pas
espoir que l'on puisse remettre les
centristes autour de la table de cette
décision et je le dis et je le dis
d'autant plus que vous voyez ces
régionales que nous avons gagné en ile
de france
nous les avons gagné parce que j'ai
réussi à faire une très très large
alliance de la droite
j'allais dire conservatrice qu'on
connaît bien jusqu'à l'extrême centre le
modem et même il ya le berling qu'il ya
quand même des verts donc on a on a
vraiment réussi à faire une majorité
d'idées guider sur un programme qui
correspondait à un certain nombre de
valeurs et on a réussi à s'identifier
tous ensemble à ce programme
bon tout le monde la primaire c'est de
coller à votre avis est-ce que vous ne
rêvez pas c'est promis parce que c'est
donnant donnant d'accord on va avec vous
la primaire mais en échange non
veut-elle pas je pense que le sujet
derrière enfin moi je vois ça en tant qu
observateur extérieur je ne suis pas du
tout dans ce processus mais j'imagine
que le sujet qui a derrière c'est les
investitures aux législatives qui
doivent être donnés au moins de juin
donc j'imagine que tout ça est un
processus encore en discussion en tout
cas je l'espère parce que ce serait tout
à fait dommageable pour la primaire qui
puisse pas y avoir de candidat centriste
et moi je souhaite qu'il y ait des
candidats centristes à la primaire et je
le demanderai à jean christophe lagarde
quand je le verrai alors on va revenir
donc à monsieur fillon qu'on entendait
tout à l'heure vous avez dit il est pas
mon candidat puisque je n'ai pas encore
décidé
enfin l'autre jour vous avez une phrase
quand même à peine sibylline je l'y
appelle sibylline en gros en substance
on ne soutient pas toujours celui pour
lequel on a le plus d'affection
donc on a tous compris ben voilà elle
soutient pas fillon est ce qu'on a bien
compris ou non mais la question qui m'a
été posée c'est vous aimez françois
fillon dont vous avez le soutenir
il s'agit de la présidence de la
république oh que oui j'ai beaucoup
d'affection pour françois mais
aujourd'hui mon sujet c'est qui sera le
meilleur président l'a enfin celle qui
vous allez ça va mais non j'ai dit que
ce serait à l'automne et j'ai dit que ce
serait au vu des projets donc la fifa
laisser les candidats
les three lions
laisser les candidats nous dire ce qu'il
pense sur le rétablissement l'autorité
de mes propositions ce qu'il pense sur
la réforme et ce qu'il pense sur la
simple vous êtes déjà en contact avec
tout ce vous leur dites voilà est-ce que
vous allez mettre ça ça et ça dans votre
programme comment ça se passe
concrètement je leur ai dit ce que
j'allais faire et je leur ai dit que je
me déterminerai en fonction de l'heure
de leur ep mais vous êtes candidate à la
primaire non mais j'ai bien l'intention
en tant que présidente de la première
région de france 2 pas restée muette sur
tout ce que je vois surtout ce que je
vis et surtout ce qu'il faut faire pour
mener un processus de réformes dans
notre pays on a vécu différemment
aujourd'hui que vous êtes vraiment la
tête de cette très belle très grande
région pas je ne sais pas si on écoute
différemment mais en tout cas moi j'ai
bien l'intention
moi j'ai bien l'intention en tout cas
sans taire totalement libre et
indépendant et de dire de manière
totalement libre et indépendante
ce que j'aurais envie de dire j'ai déjà
commencé sur la question du cumul des
mandats je les dis j'ai dit aussi ce que
je pensais
des ghettos urbains et d'une politique
absolument suicidaire qui a été menée
notamment par un certain nombre d'élus
de gauche placent allemand à kehl
justement par la gauche continue à
subventionner dans certaines villes des
hlm très sociaux et oui parce qu'en fait
j'ai dit aux sports aussi qu'ils ne
seront plus rapides subventions pour les
illégaux également vous êtes très
critiqué pour sa part d'abord sur les
questions d sur la question de la
concentration des difficultés sociales
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a des
quartiers dans lesquels il faut quand
même dire les choses certains
enseignants ne veulent plus aller
enseigner
certains enfants n'ont plus les mêmes
chances réussir parce que les le niveau
des écoles baisse la sécurité n'est pas
assurée il ya des foyers de
radicalisation donc on sait très bien
par exemple dans les hauts-de-seine les
yvelines des villes prête à accueillir
du logement très social
mik oui la question aujourd'hui c'est
bon mais résiste à la loi d'abord réduit
d'abord d'avoir ça ça c'est une idée
reçue monsieur grossiord vous avez en
ile-de-france pas pardon mais on a les
chiffres
monsieur valls et a donné en
ile-de-france sur 1300 communes
il y en a huit qui ne sont pas dans leur
trajectoire de la loi sru sélection pas
en train de construire du logement
social
quand elles sont carencés ya une
trentaine de vivre car on sait
sont dans une trajectoire pour rattraper
et vous avez huit villes qui sont en
infraction mais dans ces villes qui ne
sont pas sur leur trajectoire
vous avez deux villes ormesson et
périgny dans lesquelles l'état avait
lui-même gelé les terrains et vient de
les dégeler donc si vous voulez ça n'en
fait plus que 6 et sur les 6
alors évidemment vous avez une nuit mais
maintenant moi je voudrais juste que
l'état me dise où à neuilly il veut
construire du logement social
peut-être qu'il le paye un parce que ça
coûtera très cher les fronts celui ci
voulez vous c'est pas avec civile il ya
640 milles demande de logements non
satisfaite en ile-de-france 640 milles
c'est pas avec six communes conseil la
météo la région avec plus de mixité
sociale vérité c'est que les maires de
droite construisent en ile de france y
compris du logement social c'est ça la
vérité de jeu tout simplement revenir à
la primaire écolo a dit m
certains reprochent à monsieur juppé que
vous allez peut-être soutenir vous lui
direz ça à l'automne c'est cela de ne
pas sortir du bois de s'abriter derrière
les sondages qu'il faut dire ils sont
excellents pour lui un même si je crois
qu'il ya une baisse de 6 points là dans
un un des sondages enfin il est quand
même largement devant et est-ce que
c'est également votre sentiment vous
avez l'impression que monsieur juppé il
s'expose pas assez moi j'attends d'avoir
les projets des uns et les autres et là
encore jaya déjà pour il a déjà produit
plusieurs plusieurs documents monsieur
juppé vous pouvez pas dire qu'il n'a pas
sur ce document sur l'éducation
l'économie son document sur l'éducation
n'est pas du tout en ligne avec ce que
je pense que nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui sur l'éducation
je pense nous avons besoin d'aller plus
loin dans une réforme gelé dire plus
audacieuses et je la mènerai je
commencerai à mettre des petites graines
en ile de france puisque je ferai voter
en mai un budget d'autonomie pour les
lycées de façon à ce que les chefs
d'établissement puisque à voir avec leur
équipe et avec la communauté éducative
dans les lycées de manière expérimentale
plus d'autonomie en ile-de-france au
pouvoir porter un projet adapté à la
réalité de leur territoire y'a rien de
commun entre un lycée à sevran et un
lycée on a parlé de neuilly-sur-seine ni
sur scène il n'ya rien de commun entre
henri iv est un lycée professionnel de
seine-et-marne
donc le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est que chaque équipe doit pouvoir
avoir son tour porter son projet c'est
une idée que je n'ai pas encore retrouvé
donc le sujet c'est que voilà il faut
qu'on soit très audacieux et moi
j'attends je saurai si je sois quelqu'un
comme nathalie kosciusko morizet ou
bruno le maire qui s'autoproclament
l'homme du renouveau
madame maurice madame de nkm kibaki une
femme apparemment non il y aura aussi le
nom mme morano je crois mais là
peut-être moins de chance que nkm
d'avoir une question c'est quoi ma
question c'est est là pourquoi pas alors
choisir une femme ça ce sera audacieux
côté j'ai pas encore lu les livres
donc je vais élire il pouvait lire tous
les programmes tous les cas je vous dis
gestion personnelle et on arrivait au
delà de la lecture des livres qui
certainement va m'éclairer j'aurai un
certain nombre de questions et chasser
question j'attends des réponses en six
mois d'accord et notamment sur la
simplification la primaire on a bien
compris en 17
vous n'êtes pas candidat eh ben vous
êtes en tête en 22 alors oui mais moi
vous savez ma priorité c'est d'abord
d'avoir des résultats
parce que je crois que ce qui a jailli à
minuit mais profondément fin là on est
c'est la haye ce qui crée cette défiance
épouvantable idées politiques pensent
l'élection suivante s'énonce et c2c de
ne pas avoir de résultat et on a besoin
aujourd'hui que les engagements pris
pendant la campagne supprimer les 75 %
de réduction pour les étrangers en
situation irrégulière lutter contre les
ghettos urbains ses promesses on les met
en oeuvre j'ai dit que je baisserais
mais dotation de fonctionnement que
j'investirais dans l'avenir c'est ce que
je fais j'ai c'est d'être conforme à ce
que j'ai promis
merci valérie pécresse ou et merci à
noter ce pull jacques bonsoir à tous et
à la semaine prochaine
qui